(trumpet music)
- Morning, ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of the
president Yale University,
the commanding officer Yale University,
Naval Reserve Officers' Training Corps,
and commander Yale University
Air Force Reserve
Officers' Training Corps,
welcome to the annual President's Review.
We specifically acknowledge
and thank representatives in attendance
from Fairfield University,
Quinnipiac University,
Sacred Heart University,
Southern Connecticut State University,
Western Connecticut State University,
and the University of New Haven.
To you,
and to all distinguished guests,
families, and friends, welcome.
Today's music is being provided by
the Navy Band Northeast
Trident Brass Quintet
from Naval Station Newport, Rhode Island.
Today's review is being conducted
by the midshipmen and cadets
of the Yale University ROTC.
(murmurs)
- Forward.
Sword.
(murmurs)
- Present day review have their basis
in both history and tradition.
The mass formation of troops
on one long line at close interval
made possible the massing of firepower
from muzzle loaded muskets of yesterday.
In those early days, the
line of battle was just that,
a line of two or three ranks
and looked much like
the parade formation you will see today.
The adjacent forms the line for battle.
(murmurs)
(trumpet music)
- Battalion, attention.
(murmurs)
- Attention.
(trumpet music)
(band music)
(all conversing)
(murmurs)
- Proceed at war.
- Battalion (murmurs)
Proceed to war,
take your post.
- Battalion, order march.
(murmurs)
Battalion (murmurs)
swords.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
please rise for the arrival
of the official party.
(bell ringing)
Yale University Air Force
Reserve Officer Training Corps
Unit Detachment 009 arriving.
(bell ringing)
Yale University,
Naval Reserve Officers
Training Corps unit arriving.
- Staff order swords.
Battalion (murmurs)
(bell ringing)
- Yale University arriving.
- Staff carry swords.
(murmurs)
- [Captain May] Ladies and
gentlemen please remain standing
for the posting of the colors,
the national anthem,
and the invocation.
- Forward march.
(band music)
(murmurs)
swords.
(national anthem music)
Staff forward swords.
Battalion order arms.
(murmurs)
(band music)
Order.
Color.
(murmurs)
- Battalion (murmurs)
(all conversing)
- [Captain May] Chaplain Sharon Kugler,
Yale University chaplain
will now give the invocation.
- I invite you to join me
in the spirit of prayer.
Almighty God, source of all truth,
here we stand
humbled by the breadth of service
both past and present in our midst.
We stand proud of what
has been made possible
because we have committed ourselves
to making our world a better place
through our willing spirits,
able bodies,
and courageous hearts.
Although today is a
celebration and rightly so,
we remember those who
have given their lives
in service to their country,
and we hold close those
who are currently deployed
and ask that your gentle hand protect them
and guide them safely home.
Now may our hearts move from
gratitude to inspiration
as your divine spirit empowers us
with a renewed vision and purpose.
Let us begin this review
lifted by splendor,
ignited by camaraderie,
together in our many voices,
strengths and faiths,
and as your loving people we say Amen.
- Please be seated.
The Pass in Review has several purposes.
First it serves to honor
and thank the leadership
of the universities
that host and support our units.
This event also serves as an opportunity
to publicly recognize the achievements
of the midshipmen and
cadets you see here today,
who have distinguished themselves
during the academic year.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Commander,
Yale University,
Naval ROTC,
Captain Withrow.
(audience clapping)
- Good morning everyone.
Thank you, Captain May.
Good morning and welcome to our first
in-person President's Review
and the first military Pass
in Review since April of 2019.
It's hard to believe it's been that long.
Colonel George Granholm of Air Force ROTC
and I are proud to recognize
our cadets and midshipmen
for distinguished performance,
to recognize our graduating class of 2022,
who'll be commissioning
in just a few short weeks.
And to thank the many
family and friends of ROTC.
I'm also excited that for the
first time in several years
those Yales who are part
of the Army ROTC program
at the University of New Haven,
are able to join us today.
Before I introduce our host,
I want to make some key,
I wanna recognize some key
players in today's ceremony.
First off we have Midshipmen
Second Class Aaron (murmurs)
the Midshipmen officer in charge,
responsible for planning this grand event,
and assisting from the Air Force side
Cadet Fourth Class Shannon Palm.
My executive officer Commander Scott Ryan,
First Sergeant Roberto Portell,
master trainer and enforcer
of military drill and customs.
Let me say again, enforcer.
Tech Sergeant Patricia (murmurs)
Master Sergeant Shaniqua Hunt,
Miss Liz Villadaki,
master administrator coordinator,
ghost email writer,
et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
Also Trisha Neely, Ed Walters,
Carlos Pinella of PWG,
who has been instrumental
also in setting this up.
Thank you from meeting
with us so many times
as we've ventured over here
to set this ceremony up.
You've all been incredibly helpful.
Petty officers second
class Michael (murmurs)
and the Navy Band Quintet,
thank you for joining us.
Captain May, our masterful MC,
who will keep this show moving
on or ahead of schedule.
Those who provide never
ending support to ROTC,
for the sake of time,
I do see captain May,
I can see you from here
looking at your watch.
I'll name but a few,
recognizing those unnamed
are just as important as those I do name.
ROTC representatives
from our partner schools,
professor Gary Rose of
Sacred Heart University,
welcome.
Jason Burke, director of
veterans and military affairs
for Quinnipiac University,
president Joe Bertolino,
of Southern Connecticut State University,
and of course, captain (murmurs)
of the University of New
Haven Army ROTC program.
From Yale faculty and staff,
we have president Salovey present,
secretary vice president Goff-Crews,
Dean Chun, Dean (murmurs)
Chaplain Kugler,
YVA president Adrian Bonenberger
YVA president Shawn Flynn,
also those representing
our awarding organizations
who invest time and resources every year
undertaking the important responsibility
of recognizing our students.
Last but certainly most important,
the family and friends of support network
for our ROTC students.
Colonel Granholm I thank you,
We are proud of our
students and equally proud
and appreciative of their supporting cast.
So let's give a big round of
applause for all of those.
(all clapping)
So please relax, enjoy the show
and take plenty of photographs.
At this time it is now
my distinct pleasure
to introduce our host president
Peter Salovey of Yale University.
President Salovey has a long
and distinguished career at Yale.
He is the 23rd president
of Yale University
and the Chris Argyris
Professor of Psychology,
well known for his work on human behavior,
human emotion and health behavior,
especially his work,
co-developing the world renowned framework
called emotional intelligence.
Additionally, he is an
uplifting and sincere leader
who always inspires and
encourages everyone around him.
Whether they're faculty, staff, student,
he inspires us to work together,
in strengthening our Yale
campus, our community,
and our world through service to others.
And these fine midshipmen and cadets
that you see standing before you
all of whom upon graduation
will take a solemn oath
of service to a higher
calling to their nation,
have benefited from
president Salovey's caring,
compassionate and resolute leadership.
So ladies and gentlemen please join me
in a warm round of applause
welcoming our host
president Peter Salovey.
(all clapping)
- Thank you so much, I appreciate that.
Thank you captain Withrow
for the kind introduction
and for your service as commanding officer
of Yale's Naval Reserve
Officers Training Corps unit.
I'd also like to recognize
and thank Colonel Granholm,
for his leadership of
Yale's Air Force Reserve
Officers Training Corps unit,
as well as captain (murmurs)
of the Army Reserve
Officers' Training Corps
at the University of New Haven.
So now more than ever
we appreciate your
distinguished military careers
and your commitment to advancing stability
in the world through service.
To all the parents and loved ones,
active duty military members,
veterans who are here with us today,
I extend a warm greeting
on behalf of my colleagues
across the University.
And I wish to welcome cadets, liaisons,
and leaders from the
University of New Haven,
Southern Connecticut State University,
Quinnipiac University,
and Sacred Heart University.
We've all participated,
we've all anticipated the day
when public health
conditions would allow us
to gather again for special
ceremonies like this one.
And I'm so pleased that that day has come.
I'm pleased that
for the first time since 2019 we can honor
the hard work and dedication,
your hard work, your dedication,
of our ROTC students here in person.
Our ability to celebrate today
brings an extra measure of enthusiasm
to a milestone day.
The sense of service we mark
on this historic occasion
dates to the founding of our institution
and to the Republic.
Let me give you a few examples,
in 1701,
Yale became the first American University
to inscribe service to society
explicitly in its founding documents.
Scores of Yales have
served with distinction
in every major conflict
since the revolutionary war.
Yale Air Force ROTC,
was one of the original
77 senior air ROTC units
established by an order that
general Eisenhower signed.
And Yale was also among
the initial group of universities
to establish an ROTC program
more than a century ago.
Army ROTC in 1917,
followed by Naval ROTC in 1926,
and Air Force ROTC in 1946.
At the time Major General
Robert M. Danford predicted
the program would become
one of the many priceless heritages
of future generations at Yale.
And as I look out
in this amphitheater
I see that he was right.
The 42 Air Force cadets,
the 31 midshipmen,
and the two Army cadets,
currently participating
in Yale's ROTC program
are carrying forward the proud legacy
of those before them.
This includes the valor
of nearly 30,000 Yales,
who served in the first
and second world wars,
Korea and Vietnam.
And the spirit of sacrifice
that links these military men and women
is a hallmark of the
spirit of Yale itself.
It is the desire to serve,
to look beyond self-interest,
it is the desire to
contribute to the common good.
And it is in short the desire
to improve the world today
and for future generations.
Indeed, that is the call
of the opening sentence
of our mission statement.
And this is the call,
the class of 2022 has answered.
Your decision to serve our
country in the armed forces
is especially critical during
this period of turbulence.
We can see today
the increasing presence of
the spirit of division around the globe.
Yet today,
as we salute your accomplishments
we can also feel the thriving spirit
of the presence,
and presence of the
opportunity for service.
It's a spirit forged over centuries.
Indeed the fabric of our nation
is woven by the individuals
who have defended it
for nearly 250 years.
Their resilience, their
wisdom helped build a nation
and their strength helped bind it together
during difficult times.
Their courage helped save a
world torn apart by war twice.
Their determination has protected millions
from a life of oppression and hardship.
Their compassion has brought food,
clothing,
shelter,
and medicine to those who need it most.
And their unselfish motives
in the face of adversity brought hope
to those who are suffering.
Throughout your time at Yale,
I have seen the same sense of optimism,
courage, and selflessness in you.
And I know the class of 2022
will manage to make us even more proud
in the years ahead.
So now, I'd like to congratulate
all our students to be graduates
and express my appreciation
to all our midshipmen and cadets
for their dedication to service,
and their many contributions to Yale.
You will soon be second
lieutenants and ensigns
serving as America's
ambassadors around the world.
You'll face challenges and opportunities
in a rapidly changing global climate
with incredible technological advances
that both connect people across
national and cultural borders
but also pose unpredictable
security risks.
You'll experience shifts
in political and environmental landscapes,
yet regardless of what trials you may face
I am confident that you
like the generations of Yales
who contributed to this country before you
will lead and serve the greater good.
We are so proud of what
you have accomplished here.
We eagerly look forward
to all that you will achieve in the future
as you build on Yale's tradition
of loyal service to
community and to country.
I wanna thank everyone
for joining us today,
and I hope you cadets and midshipmen
will accept my most heartfelt
and proud congratulations.
Thank you very much.
(all clapping)
- We will now begin with
the presentation of awards.
The veterans of foreign
war award is presented by
Mr. Dominick Cortese,
veterans of foreign war commander
for the State of Connecticut.
This award recognizes
one midshipmen and one cadet in each unit
who demonstrates a positive
attitude towards ROTC,
outstanding professional attributes
and officer potential.
This year's Naval ROTC recipient
is midshipmen Courtney Johnson,
and Air Force ROTC recipient
is cadet Presley Hill.
(audience clapping)
The general society of
the war of 1812 award
is presented by Mr. Lee Tryon,
secretary of the society
of the war of 1812
for the state of Connecticut.
This award is given to one
midshipmen and one cadet
who represent the cherishing maintenance
and extension of the
institutions of American freedom
and foster true patriotism
and love of country.
This year's Naval ROTC recipient
is midshipmen Victoria (murmurs)
and Air Force ROTC recipient
is cadet Brandon Estacio.
(audience clapping)
The Yale Veterans Association
true to her traditions award
is presented by Mr. Adrian Bonenberger,
Yale University college 2002,
and Mr. Joshua Ray, Yale college 2013.
The mission of Yale University
is to educate leaders.
Additionally,
Yale University has a long
and glorious tradition
of service and defense of our country.
The Yale Veterans
Association is very pleased
to present its annual
true to her tradition's leadership award
to honor and commemorate these ideals
to the midshipmen and cadet
who have demonstrated
a strong commitment to
them over the past year.
This year's Naval ROTC recipient
is midshipmen Joseph Murphy,
and Air Force ROTC recipient
is cadet Brian Regan.
(audience clapping)
The Yale veterans
network annual ROTC award
is presented by miss Tamika Hollis,
co-chair of the Yale veterans network.
In the spirit of the Yale
veterans networks charge
to connect veterans on campus,
this award is given annually
to an ROTC midshipmen and cadet
who have demonstrated commitment
to the Yale University ROTC programs
through outstanding leadership,
discipline,
character,
citizenship,
and academic achievement.
This year's Naval ROTC recipient
is midshipmen Olivia (murmurs)
and Air Force ROTC recipient
is cadet Dominick DeFazio.
(audience clapping)
The order of the purple heart
national leadership award
is presented by Major Daniel Eddinger,
commander of the military
Order of the Purple Heart
for the state of Connecticut.
This award recognizes the
demonstrated leadership ability
of a midshipmen and cadet enrolled
in a University ROTC program.
This year's Naval ROTC recipient
is midshipmen Catherine Yang,
and Air Force ROTC recipient
is Cadet Catherine Yerger.
(audience clapping)
The Rear Admiral Frederick B. Warder Award
for outstanding achievement
will be presented by captain Vernon Pats,
United States Navy retired.
The Rear Admiral Frederick B. Warder Award
for outstanding achievement
established in 1986
recognizes graduating NROTC seniors
approved for entry into
the Navy's nuclear propulsion program
as submarine officers.
The awardee has demonstrated
a superior sustained performance
in a difficult and challenging academic
and operational environment.
And as a result has earned
the commanding officer's nomination
for this distinctive award.
This year's recipient is
midshipmen Cynthia (murmurs)
(audience clapping)
The corporal Langdon Laws Ricketts award
is presented by Mr. Adrian Bonenberger.
Corporal Ricketts graduated
from Yale College in 1916,
and was killed in action
during World War I,
at Mont Blanc in 1918.
A decorated Marine
who was a recipient of the (murmurs)
all accounts maintain
that Corporal Ricketts
had a knack for maintaining
his wits in the face of chaos.
Importantly, he was an enlisted man,
a non-commissioned officer.
NCOs are the backbone of the Marine Corps.
More than any other service,
the Marines place special
trust and confidence
in the abilities of their
junior most enlisted leadership.
It is this sort of
Marine that the recipient
of the corporal Langdon
Laws Ricketts award
will be called upon to lead shortly
after their graduation from Yale college.
This year's recipient is
midshipmen Aaron (murmurs)
(audience clapping)
The Hiram Bingham III
award is presented by
Colonel Granholm, commander
Yale Air Force ROTC,
in honor of the esteem Yale
University academic explorer
and politician Hiram Bingham III,
this award is presented
to urge its awardee
to always fight for truth,
justice and mercy,
and to serve as a reminder to them
to fear nothing except to do wrong.
This award is given to the senior cadet
who exhibits the highest
level of integrity
and American citizenship.
This year's award recipient
is cadet Julia Sanderson.
(audience clapping)
The Robert Andar award is presented by
Mr. Kevin Gunther,
United States Air Force retired.
Robert Andar was an
esteem teacher and mentor
to generations of US Air
Force language specialists.
This award is presented
to a Yale University Air Force ROTC cadet
for excellence in academic achievement
and for inspiring others toward
global cultural awareness.
This year's award winner
is cadet Grace Zarba.
(audience clapping)
The Yale Veterans Association
class of 1966 sword
is presents by Mr. Fred
Nagle, Yale college 1966,
chairman emeritus Yale
Veterans Association.
This sword is awarded
to midshipmen Dan Wayne,
an individual, a Naval ROTC student
who possesses a demonstrated
leadership ability
and who has earned the
respect of Yale classmates
inside and outside of the NROTC program.
Through his efforts he
has materially contributed
to bridging the civilian military divide,
and by exerting leadership in both spheres
has enhanced the prestige of
the NROTC program on campus
and reinforced the Yale tradition
of engaging in service to society
as a desirable life objective.
(audience clapping)
The Admiral David S.
Engels leadership award
is presented by Mr. Redman
S. Engels, Yale College 1998.
The Admiral David S. Engels
award is presented to
a senior Yale Naval ROTC student
who shows uncommon ability
and leadership potential.
David S. Engels Yale college
was a Navy's first ace
with five confirmed kills in World War I.
He later served as assistant secretary
of the Navy for aeronautics
where he tripled the
number of Navy aircraft
while advocating for a fully
deployable carrier task force.
At Yale he twice capped
in the men's hockey team.
This year's recipient is
midshipmen, Sidney (murmurs)
(audience clapping)
The Yale veterans ROTC
fund award is presented by
Mr. Peter Salovey, president Yale college.
This award is given to a
Yale senior in the Army,
Air Force, and Naval ROTC units,
who is in good standing in their unit
with excellent academic
and military performance records.
This year's Navy recipient
is midshipmen Andrews Sung,
who is not in attendance
due to his Naval reactor's
technical interview.
The Air Force recipient
is cadet N. (murmurs)
and Army recipient is cadet Greg (murmurs)
(audience clapping)
This concludes the individual
award presentations.
Please join me in giving
a round of applause
to our midshipmen and cadets
who are undertaking extra
academic coursework,
undergoing physical training,
participating in numerous
community events,
and willingly have pledged
to serve their country upon graduation.
(all clapping)
- Battalion, attention.
(all conversing)
(upbeat music)
March.
(murmurs)
Swords.
Pose.
March.
(all conversing)
Officers pose.
March.
Battalion (murmurs)
(murmurs)
- Ladies and gentlemen,
we will now recognize the Class of 2022.
Please hold your applause
until everyone has been recognized.
Midshipmen Cynthia (murmurs)
from Glastonbury, Connecticut
of Berkeley college.
First assignment, Naval
and nuclear power school,
Charleston South Carolina.
Midshipmen Sidney (murmurs)
from Brentwood, Tennessee
of (murmurs) College.
First assignment,
USS Pinckney, San Diego, California.
Midshipmen Olivia Plant
from Baltimore, Maryland,
of Timothy Dwight College.
First assignment,
Naval flight training, Pensacola, Florida.
Midshipmen Andrew Sung
from Palo Alto, California
of Pearson college.
First assignment,
Naval nuclear power school,
Charleston South Carolina.
Midshipmen (murmurs)
from New York, New York,
of Davenport College.
First assignment,
Naval flight training, Pensacola, Florida.
Midshipmen Caroline Thomason
from Clayton, Missouri,
of Morse College.
First assignment,
Naval flight training, Pensacola, Florida.
Cadet (murmurs) from
Los Angeles, California,
of Morse College.
First assignment, intelligence officer,
Goodfellow Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Maria Cannon from
Jacksonville, Florida,
of Davenport College.
First assignment, combat systems officer,
Pensacola, Florida.
Cadet Dominic DeFazio
from Brussels, Belgium
of Davenport College.
First assignment, pilot trainee,
Sheppard Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet David Gallagher from
Los Altos, California,
of Ezra Stiles college.
First assignment, acquisitions officer,
Hanscom Air Force Base, Massachusetts.
Cadet Emily Heller from
Whitesboro, New York,
of the University of New Haven.
First assignment, intelligence officer,
Goodfellow Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Andrew (murmurs) from
Temple City, California,
of Saybrook College.
First assignment, pilot trainee,
Vance Air Force base, Oklahoma.
Cadet Carson Messick from Clifton, Texas,
of Saybrook College.
First assignment, intelligence officer,
Goodfellow Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Michael Mohamed
from New York, New York,
of the University of New Haven.
First assignment, undergraduate
air battle manager training,
Tyndall Air Force Base, Florida.
Cadet Elizabeth Nasser from Boise, Idaho,
of Franklin college.
First assignment, intelligence officer
Goodfellow Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet N. (murmurs)
from Prescott, Arizona,
of Jonathan Edwards college.
First assignment, pilot trainee,
Columbus, Mississippi.
Cadet Shannon Palm from
Guilford, Connecticut,
of Quinnipiac University School of Law.
First assignment, judge advocate,
Maxwell Air Force Base, Alabama.
Cadet, Molly (murmurs)
from Westminster, Maryland,
of (murmurs) college.
First assignment, Air Force
health profession scholar,
Columbia University
College of Dental Medicine,
New York, New York.
Cadet Julia Sanderson
from Centreville, Virginia
of Branford College.
First assignment, intelligence officer,
Goodfellow Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Matthew Schneider from
Raleigh, North Carolina,
of Pauli Murray college.
First assignment, pilot training,
Laughlin Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Alexandra Shore
from Washington, D.C.,
of Saybrook College.
First assignment, acquisitions officer,
Hanscom Air Force Base, Massachusetts.
Cadet Rachel (murmurs)
from Bayside, Wisconsin,
of Ezra styles college.
First assignment, explosive
ordinance disposal officer,
Fort Lee, Virginia.
Cadet Greg (murmurs)
from Milford, Connecticut,
of Pauli Murray College.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please join me in a round of applause
for our graduating senior.
(audience clapping)
- Staff attention.
Battalion attention.
(murmurs)
- [Captain May] Ladies and
gentlemen please rise
for the benediction,
and remain standing
for the Pass in Review,
service songs, and departure
of the official party.
- My sisters and brothers let us go forth
from this place in peace,
with wisdom and understanding,
with compassion and mercy,
with courage and commitment.
May we be blessed this day and every day
by the shimmering light of our God,
who creates, sustains,
and embraces all life.
Amen.
(murmurs)
- Forward march.
Forward march.
(band music)
(murmurs)
(all units singing)
- Dismiss your company.
(murmurs)
- Dismissed.
(all conversing)
- Ladies and gentlemen,
this concludes today's ceremony.
We invite all presenters
and award recipients
to join us at center court to take photos.
Thank you for attending
and please join us for
refreshments in the lobby.
(audience clapping)